يوجه خطاب ناريا لحشد من مناصريه او يتوسط
قاده مجموعه العشرين لالتقاط صوره تذكاريه
يتبادل اطراف الحديث معبوت او يستقبل
الزعيم الليبي الراحل معمر القذافي وقد
يتلقى لكمه في حفل فتسيل الدماء من وجهه
او يعتمر خوذه لمساعده فريق النقاب يتصدر
اسمه الصحف بسبب فضائح واتهامات جنسيه
وتتم مسالته في البرلمان ويمثل امام
المحاكم هذه مشاهد من حياه من يوصف بانه
اكثر الرجال نفوذا في تاريخ ايطاليا
الذي ظل متمسكا بطموحه السياسي حتى اخر
ايامه داعيا مناصريه للاقتراع في
الانتخابات البلديه عبر شريط فيديو سجله
من المستشفى
اعتذر على ازعاجكم ولكن اود تذكيركم ان
الاحد والاثنين اي بعد غد وفي اليوم الذي
يليه هناك انتخابات اداريه لرؤساء
البلديات في 700 بلده ومدينه في ايطاليا
يعتبر بيرلس كوني احد الرجال الاكثر ثراء
في بلاده يمتلك اكبر شبكه تلفزيونيه
تجاريه والعديد من الاستثمارات الاخرى دخل
معترك السياسه عام
وحكمك رئيس وزراء لتسع سنوات كان لها
التاثير الاعمق في وجه ايطاليا المعاصر
اود ان اقول ان بيرلس كوني كان له تاثير
هائل بشكل عام على الثقافه الايطاليه اي
على عقليه الناس عندما ادخل التلفزيون
التجاري في بدايه الثمانينيات كانت
ايطاليا منقسمه بشكل اساسي بين الثقافه
الكاثوليكيه التقليديه والثقافه الشيوعيه
اليسريه وقد قدم بيل سكوني نوعا جديدا من
الفكر التقدمي وقاده عمليه التغيير نحو
مجتمع مدني
في سنواته الاخيره فضائح جنسيه واتهم فساد
برئ منها وانتخب عضوا في مجلس الشيوخ وقد
احتفظ الرجل بمكانه خاصه في قلوب ملايين
الايطاليين وتحديدا مشجعي فريق ميلان الذي
امتلكه برلسكوني الذي نحو ثلاثين عاما
وحقق معه الكثير من البطولات قبل بيعه
لمستثمرين صيني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات